master p did it he's a rapper
uh cash money they did it 50 cent did it
jay-z did it
because they built their own table
antoine when you were in the music
industry
how often was the most successful artist
the most talented
um not so much
because a lot of times it's politics
sometimes politics over our talent so
nowadays i tell people
talent being talented is not enough you
can't be a one-trick pony you gotta do
different things so when i was in the
music business there were so many
talented people
but they didn't get they shot because
they know this person this is a little
politics game
so a lot of times the people didn't get
to eat shot
yeah so it really came down to them not
knowing someone yeah not knowing
somebody
this and that and you have some people
that actually made it
um but
you know they fade out so
now it's a business a politics if you're
talented as a bonus but it's a lot of
politics in any type of
organization that's so popular
yeah
can we break down what politics means to
the music industry yes with any any
industry so
sometimes it'd be an individual
that's really talented like really
talented
artists but
they don't play the politics game
positives game could be you don't have a
lot of money to pay a dj
um you don't know the certain producer
um you're not willing to sacrifice your
morals to get to the next level this is
an oil and this is all type of fields
this is a regular job sometimes you have
a boss
that
one take advantage of you to get to the
next level that's go back to my point
about knowing yourself because a lot of
leeches out there a lot of predators out
there in all industries in life
so that's the politics
so while they get around the politics
is the best moon yourself
instead of waiting for a sea at the
table you build your own table
uh
massive p did it he's a rapper
uh cash money they did it 50 cent did it
jay-z did it
because they built their own table from
their career they were trying everybody
said no shut the door
and they built their own table that's
how you get around politics because you
become the nerve of your own story
did you see people
with that mindset still get swallowed up
not really um i mean you're gonna get a
little bit but not really because you
don't control your own destiny i've seen
people that didn't do that and got take
advantage of because they didn't know
the value of yourself
so
that's why i tell know yourself like i
had a friend well my um homegirl
talented artist
she was with this producer it was making
music
and he made advance at her
um
and she said you know what i'm not into
it
she he tried to blackball her so a lot
of studios in the neighborhood don't
mess with this girl she's difficult she
wasn't difficult you was trying to do
something with her that was
inappropriate so these are things you
got to watch out for the leech and and
and know and a lot of people if you
don't know your value you're going to do
it think you're gonna get ahead
but you don't have to do that that's
what i love today now there's no
gatekeepers
how long were you in the music industry
before you realized that the most
talented artist
was not always the most successful
all right so i got into it
because i've seen some you see it now so
many talented people but they don't get
their chance and sometimes it's like
that life ain't fit right so you're
gonna find that like me i'm a talented
person
but i'm not there wherever i was at
because i'm taking the long way
it's times i could have took shortcuts i
could have done certain things but
my morals and values won't don't allow
it so
sometimes you gotta take the long way
but eventually you get to your
destination
what are shortcuts
and then and in my world shulkers was
uh
i mean i went to this party and i needed
for one of my films
and it was like a cult it's a coke party
it was a cook party so i went there and
i wanted to meet this producer and he
was interested in one of my projects to
invest in but he was doing coke
and you know you should take a hit i
don't do coke i didn't come in and do
coke i can't have a meeting so that's
the politics in advance now if i didn't
know myself
i would've
took some coke i would've wanted to play
the game but that just wasn't me um
while i was filming lola won
um i had an investor
she didn't want to invest in the film
because my league actress taj v simpsons
was doxing
she wanted a lighted person
so i knew my value
i'm not playing that
light game to appeal to a wide orders a
caucasian orders so i decided i'm gonna
stick to my guns i'm gonna get a darker
female for my film i won't do the film
like i want to do it so those are things
that we we don't hear about but it's all
happening behind the scenes of getting
to the next level
that was actually said yes
and so
how
i realized this is touchy but you know
it's not okay yeah so for me when a
person told me that i said okay i invest
in my own movie
because i'm not going to be swimming by
no dollar i'm from no i come from a
different era so we hustle our own
things we don't that's why when i came
in the film industry it was so many
things going on i was like why are y'all
waiting like
but i have a different mindset maybe if
i have the film
experience i might be like everybody
else but i came in this game like really
hustling invested in my own films and
because i realized that
no one's going to be to hear about my
story i got to be here with my story
yeah so when you when you saw that email
or got that text or got that phone call
you knew okay this is time to part ways
yes
because you know at the end of the day
if someone giving you money
it's going to come with some things
that situation i ain't like that and i
speak about it in other interviews and i
tell sometimes in the industry
they would cast a lighter person a more
light-like person to appeal to white
orders because they could sell it more
and is it true i don't care but is this
true could people do it i'll give you
example
um denzel washington
and he talked about they talked about
this you can find this article when they
was promoting it overseas and try to
make it really big america gangster they
put russell crowe in the poster and
russell crowe was a
he wasn't that big in the film but he
put him in the poster
the pillars of wide orders
i even go down to 50 cent 50 cent got
show called power
when he was promoting power they had to
put uh
the guy that played um tommy
on the cover the pilot orders it could
just be the main actor uh a monkey
hallway so this is a politics game
people don't realize that that does
happen in this industry
were you making good money in the music
industry no it was making nothing it was
horrible i was spending way more money
than because with the music industry
it's like the lottery it's a hit or miss
yes i was making zero nothing what were
you spending it on
all this stuff uh
videos i was a manager so i was
investing into the artist and not only
make no money back but what i did made
was experience
that allowed me to take it to the film
industry so i used my short films
as my mixtapes
and my feature films as my albums
so i use that analogy they slide into
the film industry but i have i had some
great experience i make no money but
great experience
so you were working these other jobs
hotels security all these different
things and doing this
and how tired were you i was it when you
have something that you love you don't
tire
and so it's so
it's so rewarding it's amazing to come
up with ideas in your head and you don't
need a degree you don't need you just
need a passion and a drive so i i was
tired
and when did you leave the music
industry
maybe
10 years ago
right around the time you had sort of
this revelation that you did i was
dibbling and dab i was sliding out but
officially ten years ago
did you did you have to tell the artist
some of the artists that you're working
with that you're sorry oh they know i
was leaving oh they knew okay i was like
i'm going yeah i got to figure it out
and i left and it was a great decision
because
it made me realize my value my worth
and when i got into the film industry i
fell in love i know that i tell people
too
you want to do something with your life
fall in love with something when you
fall in love with something you do
anything
how many times do you have a
relationship with girls or a guy you did
anything for that fall in love with
something and it'd be the best thing
so once you
once you sort of like gave your own
notice to yourself
um you gave your two weeks notice
um what were some of the first things
you started doing for the film industry
first building a company
so i started answering films
and i wanted to brand myself and do all
that stuff and then i did my first short
film switch decision won tons of awards
and then i did a feature film called
life too short um
went tons of awards international
domestically and i kept going and i
loved every minute of it i was telling
all different stories
and i really like it was it was great
because
i would control everything there wasn't
an artist with me out the artist
and
it worked out perfectly
and you were still working these jobs
too
to pay for okay
hotels can pay really well yeah yeah i
just gave up my job a year before covert
oh wow okay yeah okay yeah and sometimes
these hotel jobs too you have these
flexible hours yeah it was makeups in
union making like 35 hours wow so i was
i was good but it sounds good but in new
york city it's like huh
if i was living somewhere else like in
atlanta
i'd be rich but in new york city it's
just not enough did you have a car or no
no okay yeah uber or every day okay oh
over here
you